تتجه الانظار الى قاعده رمشتاين الجويه في
المانيا حيث يلتقي وزراء دفاع دول الغربيه
في اجتماع هامه بهدف تنسيق تقديم المزيد
من الدعم لاوكرانيا الرئيس الاوكراني
فولدومرنسكي يطالب بصوت عال وواضح ارسال
الدروع ثقيله لمساعده بلاده وقد ابدى
التفاؤلا بشان اتخاذ قرارات قويه لامداد
بلاده بمزيد من الاسلحه الغربيه خلال
اجتماع الحلف
اشكر السيد سالم
والذي دعا اوروبا بوضوح شديد لاتحاد قرار
بشان الدبابات لقد شكل بالفعل تحالف
لشركائه والان نحن ننتظر قرار عاصمه
اوروبيه لتفعيل هذه السلسله من التعاون في
مجال الدبابات
وقبل ساعه قليله من الاجتماع كشفت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عن حزمه جديده
من المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا بقيمه
2.5 مليار دولار تشمل خصوصا مئات المركبات
المدرعه من انواع مختلفه لا تضم دبابات
ثقيله من جهتها تعهدت بريطانيا تزويد
اوكرانيا ب 600 صاروخ اضافي من طرازي
برايم فيما وعدت الدنمارك بتزويدها ب 19
مدفع قيصر فرنسيه صنع
كل هذا مع تزايد الضغوط على المانيا لكي
توافق على دعم اوكرانيا بدبابات قتاليه من
طرازي ليوبارد اثنين الالمانيه الصنع خاصه
مع اعلان بولندا وبريطانيا عزمهم التوريد
الدبابات قتاليه ثقيله لاوكرانيا